ليس من الصحيح أن اليوم
أنا أقول للشخص اللي عنده إعاقة
يحتاج كرسي أو كذا أن أنا راح أصرف لك ضمان اجتماعي
بينما المفترض أن أنا أقول له، لا
تعال أساعدك في حالة الإعاقة
الناس يتساءلون على مفهوم
تحويل الدعم من فرد إلى أسرة
لأنه صار يمثل عبء
تحويل هؤلاء المستفدين من أشخاص متلقين للدعم فقط
إلى أشخاص قادرين على العمل
ومن ثم رفع مستوى المعيشة
وتحسين الدخل من خلال العمل
في أسئلة كثيرة من السيدات
تحديدًا السيدات اللي في سن العمل
أنه ليش تجبرونا على العمل وإحنا ما عندنا عائل
للأطفال وراعي في البيت غيرنا
هذا سقراط من شركة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
استضيف قادة التحول،وقادة الأعمال، وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الدكتور حمد الحماد
الوكيل المساعد للسياسات والتشريعات
بوكالة الضمان الاجتماعي والتمكين
في وزارة المواد البشرية والتنمية الاجتماعية
موضوع الضمان الاجتماعي موضوع
جدًّا مهم، لأنه يلامس الشريحه الأكثر احتياجًا
للدعم في السعودية
الملف هذا عاش قصة تحول ما بين نظام الدعم السابق
ونظام الدعم الحالي فكان مهم أن نوثق
هذا التحول من خلال هذه الحلقة، ونتعرف على
تاريخ موجز لموضوع الضمان من الستين سنة الماضية
التحولات اللي مر فيها، آخر نظام وآحدث نظام
وأيش الفرق بينهم
انتقلنا من دعم مُرتبط بالمسميات والحالات
إلى دعم مرتبط باحتياج حقيقي
سولفنا عن مصادر هذا الدعم
وسولفنا عن آليات استحقاق هذا الدعم
ومن الشرائح المستفيدة منه؟
وكيف يتم التقديم عليه
وكيف يتم التأكد والتثبت من الاستحقاق؟
ثم ختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلة أصدقائنا المستفيدين من الضمان
اللي أكرمونا بمجموعة من أسئلتهم الثمينة
مثل، ليش شرط عقد الإيجار؟
اللي قاعد يعيق بعضهم الاستفادة من الدعم
ليش اشتراط الزيارات الدورية اللي حاليًّا ترهق بعض الأسر
وتزعجهم وغيرها من أسئلتكم الثمينة
هذه الحلقة برعاية شركة «صفا» أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله، أبو إبراهيم شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يحييك، أرحب فيك، وأرحب في الفريق كامل
شرفتوني اليوم في الوزارة
احنا المتشرفين
شكرًا أنكم أنقذونا، المكان اللي نصوره فيه
صار فيه ظرف، فشكرًا لكم
استضفتونا بدل ما احنا نستضيفكم
أبدًا احنا سعيدين جدًّا، وشرف لنا كبير
وأنا مبسوط بهذا الظرف الحقيقة
مع التمني، إن شاء الله
ما يحصل لكم أي إعاقات في عملكم دائمًا
لكن احنا سعيدين تشريفكم لنا في الوزارة
تكونوا أقرب للفريق
وتشوفون الأعمال بصورة مباشرة
أبركها من ساعة والله، أبو إبراهيم جائتنا مجموعة اسئلة
لما أعلننا عن الحلقة، ولفتني نظري سؤال
ما له دخل بموضوعنا، بس له علاقة بشخصك
قال لي السائل أسأله، هل كونه قاضي سابق
جاب معاه نفس العقلية في مسألة الأبيض والأسود
واللي لا تعني مدحة أو ذم بقدر ما أنها أسلوب في القرار
وأسلوب في العمل
احنا نفخر بكل منسوبي مرفق القضاء
ونعتز بكفاءات عالية في السعودية من القضاة
بس هو يتكلم على أسلوب الإدارة، وأسلوب العمل
هل أنت بعدما طلعت من القضاء
لسه قاعد تدير العمل كمحكمة؟
القضاء يمكن من المهم جدًّا الإشارة إلى جزئية
تتعلق بتصحيح معلومة الأسود الأبيض
يعني هذه مهمة جدًّا، اليوم القضاء ينظر إلى البيِّنات
والقضاء وفق ما يُقدم أو يُعرض أمامه من بيانات
يستطيع الوصول إلى الحقائق
القضاء لا يعني إثبات حق
على أرض الواقع، هو في الأصل أن يكون حق
وإنما هذا هو ما أوصل أو أوصلت البيانات إلى هذه النتيجة
ولكن ما يقدم أمام القاضي
ويعرض أمامه من البيانات هو يوصل إلى هذا النتيجة
يعني يا يمين يا يسار؟
هذا في أصل
أحيانًا بعض الأمور في حياة العمل تتطلب تريث ومرونة
تبدأ شوي ثم تغير، هذه كلها ما هي موجودة
في طبيعة عمل القضاء ولّا لا؟
لا، أنا أفترض أن القاضي
هو أكثر شخص مفروض أن يكون عنده التحقق
والوصول إلى البيّنات، وأنه يكون في مرونة كبيرة
في سماع الرأي الأول، وكذلك الرأي الآخر
ثم ينظر البينات، ويتطلع عليها، ويصل إلى النتيجة
العمل في الشؤون الاجتماعية
هو عمل أمانةً مشرف جدًّا
ويعني كبقية الأعمال الموجودة
ويساعد بشكل كبير في الوصول إلى المستفيدين
من خدمات الوزارة بشكلها الكامل
كما أن القضاء ينزل إلى القضايا بصورة مباشرة، ويفصل فيها
فوزارة المواردة البشرية تنزل إلى الأعمال والخدمات
بصورة مباشرة وتنفذ هذه الخدمات
فالجميع يُقدم خدماتها بصورة كاملة
وأمانةًً أشوفه في عملي السابق والعمل الحالي
بشكل كبير جدًّا وأرى أنه اليوم
إدارة الأعمال سواءً كانت من نظرة الشؤون الاجتماعية
أو نظرة القضايا لا شك أنه تختلف
بحكم طبيعة العمل، العمل القضائي مختلف في
طبيعته عن العمل في الشأن الاجتماعي
وإحنا اليوم ما راح نناقش طبعًا العمل القضائي
ولكن تركيزنا راح يكون على موضوع
التحول في الضمان الاجتماعي أنت
أبو براهيم الوكيل المساعد لقطاع الضمان الاجتماعي
والملفت أنه في قصة التحول في هذا المكان
أغلب الناس ما يعرفونها فهدف هذه الحلقة
أننا نتعرف على تاريخ موضوع الضمان
من هم الضمانيين
أيش اللي كان يقدم لهم، وأيش التحول اللي صار؟
وراح نغطي في نهاية الحلقة مجموعة من تساؤولات الأصدقاء
المستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي
من وين ودّك تبدأ أبو إبراهيم؟
والله مهم جدًّا نشير إلى تاريخ الضمان اليوم عندنا في السعودية
الضمان الاجتماعي بالمناسبة هو اليوم
قطع قرابة اثنين وستين سنة
الضمان الاجتماعي أشار للنظام الأساسي في
الحكم في عدد من المواد من ضمنها المادة سبعة وعشرين
وأشارت إلى أن الدولة تدعم نظام الضمان
الاجتماعي وهذا جزء مهم جدًّا
للتأكيد على أن الدولة، رعاها الله، حريصة
دائمًا على تقديم الدعم والنظر إلى حال أفراد
المجتمع بصورة كاملة، وكذلك المساهمة في رفع
مستوى المعيشة لجميع الأفراد، لمّا ننظر إلى
المراحل اللي مر فيها الضمان الاجتماعي، نجد
أنها مراحل متنوعة أو مراحل مديدة
خليني أعطيك على سبيل المثال نتكلم عن نشأة
الضمان كان عام 1962 ميلادي
بدأ كمصلحة للضمان الاجتماعي في ذاك الوقت
كان الدعم يقدم كل ثلاثة أشهر
ويقدم بمبلغ قدرة 370 ريال
لمن؟
للمستحقين من الضمان الاجتماعي في ذلك الوقت
الفئات الأكثر حاجة، وبالمناسبة كان الضمان
الاجتماعي لابد من أنه يقوم فريق مصلحة
الضمان الاجتماعي بزيارة الأسرة، وتحديد
إذا كانت الأسرة مستحقة أو غير مستحقة
360 ريال؟
370 ريال
370 ريال كل ثلاثة شهور
كل ثلاثة أشهر بعد كذا، أعطى الضمان
نقلة كبيرة وأصبح وكالة في وزارة
العمل والشؤون الاجتماعية ذاك الوقت
و هذا كان عام 1975
التحول هذا غيّر في بعض المعادلات، وحتى زاد
من قيمة المعاش
الضماني للأسر، وأصبحت الأسرة تأخذ بشكل
سنوي شيك قدرة 16200 ريال
كان يقدم بهذا الشكل
مبلغ مقطوع مرة واحدة في السنة
مبلغ مقطوع يقدم مرة واحدة في عام 2005
استقلت وزارة الشؤون الاجتماعية عن
وزارة العمل وفي هذه الفترة
صدر نظام الضمان الاجتماعي اللي كان عام 1427
وأيضًا غير كثير من المعايير، وأصبح
الضمان الاجتماعي يستهدف الحيثيات
فينظر إلى الأسرة كأفراد مثستقلين
ينظر إلى اليتيم، وإلى المعاق، وإلى الكبير في
السن وغيرهم الحيثيات، والضمان الاجتماعي في
هذا الوقت تحول من سنوي إلى شهري وأصبح
الضمان بمعدل سنوي لسقف
قدرة واحد وثلاثين ألف ريال هذه الفترة استمرت
واحد وثلاثين ألف ريال في السنة
واحد وثلاثين ألف ريال في السنة كسقف للأسر في ذاك الوقت
بعد كذا جاء الـ...
تحت مظلة رؤية السعودية 2030 أصبح التغير على
مستوى كافة الأصيدة عندنا في السعودية
التطور كبير، لذلك تزامن مع هذه الفترة
صدور نظام الضمان الاجتماعي الجديد
وهذا كان عام 1442 هجري في شهر أربعة
اللي غير كثير حقيقة من المعايير
وأعتقد أنه من المهم جدًّا أن نتطرق عليها في أثناء الحلقة
ولكن من المهم الإشارة إلى جزئية مهمة
في هذا الشق، وهي أن الضمان الاجتماعي
الجديد غير حتى في قيمة المعاش بصورة مضاعفة
اليوم نتكلم عن ضمان سنوي يصل إلى ستين ألف ريال للأسرة
ويضيف برامج دعم مساند قدرها تتجاوز أربعة عشر ألف
في سقف هذا المساعدة
لذلك أنت اليوم تتكلم عن تغير
ستين ألف مقارنةً بكم قبل؟
بواحد وثلاثين ألف ريال، فأنت تتكلم عن نقلها كبيرة جدًّا
أيضًا غير الفكرة الأساسية من الضمان الاجتماعي
صار ينظر إلى الأسر الأكثر
استحقاقًا، فهو يقول لك أن أنظر إلى حد مانع
هذا الحد يجب أنه أي أسرة تكون أقل من عنده
كان دخل الأسرة لا يلبي احتياجاتها الأساسية
فإن هذه الأسرة تكون مستحقة للضمان الاجتماعي
أيضًا جاب فكرة منبثقة من رؤية السعودية
رؤية السعودية تقوم مثلما هو معروف على ثلاثة ركائز
مجتمع حيوي، ووطن طموح
واقتصاد مزدهر، ويتفرع منها عدد من الأهداف
لو نظرنا إلى الأهداف في المستوى الثالث سبعة وتسعين هدف
نشوف أنه من ضمن هذه الأهداف هدف يقول:
تمكين المستفيدين من خلال منظومة الخدمات الاجتماعية
على أساس أصل إلى تحقيق هذا الهدف
لابد أني أوفر أربع مبادرات
وبالمناسبة هذه المبادرة الأربع حققتها
الوزارة بنسبة 100% والحمد لله
المبادرات الأربعه كانت تعديل نظام الضمان الاجتماعي
ولائحته التنفيذية، وكان الغرض من هذه أنه
أعدل في القواعد بحيث أنه نستطيع من خلال
هذا النظام تحقيق هذا الهدف، لأن أنت تغير
الفكرة الأساسية من الضمان، تغير الفئة
المستهدفة من الضمان
تضع بعض الشروط، وتخفف بعض الشروط
تنظر لأشياء كثيرة فكان لزامًا تعدل نظام الضمان
الاجتماعي ولائحته التنفيذية
أيضًا من المبادرات كانت مبادرة إيجاد منصة إلكترونية
المنصة الإلكترونية كان هدف منها شغلتين
الأولى تسهيل الوصول للمستفيد، وتسهيل وصول المستفيد إلى الوزارة
فأنت اليوم تتكلم عن عمليات تقنية الوصول
فيها بشكل لحظي، وبالإضافة إلى تسهيل عملية
مُتابعة المستفيد للأخذ بيده إلى المستوى
الأفضل، والمستوى الأعلى الجزئية الثانية هي
إيجاد شراكات مع القطاع الخاص، وإيجاد برامج
تدريبية وغيرها، المهم أن تكون هذه البرامج
منتهية بالتوظيف حتى تحقق التمكين
المبادرة الرابعة هي مبادرة
إنشاء وتنفيذ عدد من الحملات الإعلامية
والتوعوية حتى توصل الفكرة بصورة مباشرة
للمستفيدين، وتحقق الغرض المشهود منها
يمكن احنا أبو إبراهيم راح توسع أكثر في أيش اللي صار
لكن قبل أن أنتقل إلى هذيك المنطقة
أبغى أتأكد أننا فاهمين
أيش كانت المشكلة في النموذج السابق حتى
نحتاج أننا نُحدثه، قد يكون هو نموذج ممتاز
لمرحلة معينة
و يشكر كل من عمل عليها لكننا اليوم احنا سوينا
بتغيير جوهري وجذري
في نظام الضمان الاجتماعي، أشرح لي أيش كانت
المشكلة في النظام السابق
وأيش الاختلاف في النظام الجديد
خليني أقول لك اليوم إذا وسّعنا المظلة
بصورة أعم اليوم رؤية السعودية 2030
تتكلم عن عدد من الركائز الأساسية عسى أصل
إلى الركائز الأساسية، لابد أن يكون عندي عدد من
التحولات والتغيير للوصول إلى الأفضل اليوم
وقد يكون عندي ممارسات ممتازة وجيدة وهي
مطبقة بشكل جيدن واستمرت إلى سنوات وهي
جهود كبيرة، ونفخر فيها إذا تبغى
أن تصعد إلى مستوى أعلى ومستوى أفضل، لابد أنه
يكون عندك عدد من التحولات، والتغيير إلى
الوصول إلى النموذج الأفضل، اليوم أنا لما
أتكلم عن فئات تحصل على معاش الضمان الإجتماعي
من كان المستحق سابقًا؟
في السابق كان النظام مثلما ذكرنا ينظر إلى الحيثيات
فنقول اليوم إذا كان عندي يتيم
بسطها يا أبو إبراهيم أنت، ماشاء الله، عليك
مصعب العبارات أيش يعني الحيثيات؟
الحيثيات هي الحالة الإجتماعية اللي يكون عليها
الإنسان، لنفترض اليوم أن عندنا معاق هل
المعاق مستحق لضمان الإجتماعي؟ في النظام
السابق كان يقول نعم لأنه المعاق يستحق الضمان الاجتماعي
إذا وجد عندي يتيم
هل لأنه يتيم، يستحق الضمان الاجتماعي؟ هذه
هي كانت الفكرة منه، إذا وجد عندي مطلقة، هل
وجود الطلاق أصبحت الآن مستحقة للضمان
الاجتماعي؟ في السابق كان يُنظر لها بهذه الطريقة
اليوم النظام المطور ما ينظر بهذه النظرة
إنما ينظر بصورة أشمل وأوسع لأن اليوم
الضمان الاجتماعي أصبح أكثر انفتاحًا
الضمان الاجتماعي دخل فيه عدد كبير من
الأفراد بعد صدور نظام الضمان المطور
واستبعد منه كثير من الأفراد أيضًا
استبعد منه غير المستحقين وفق قواعد نظام
الاجتماعي الجديد، لأن هؤلاء الأشخاص لا تنطبق
عليهم المعايير
مثل؟
مثل الحد المانع، فلو فرضنا أنه في عندنا
الأسرة تستطيع تلبية الاحتياجات الأساسية بتكوين
الأسرة بشكلها الكامل، يعني لنفترض أنه عندنا
أسرة مكونة مثلًا من أربعة أشخاص، من بين
هؤلاء الأشخاص الأربعة شخص معاق ولكن هذه
الأسرة بمجموعة دخلها تلبي احتجاز الأساسية
بصورة كاملة، فعندها دخل جيد لدى هذه الأسرة
فالضمان المطور اليوم يقول هذه الأسرة أصبحت
غير مستحقة، لأن مجموعة الدخل تجاوز الحد
المالي، بينما اليوم إذا أنت رحت نظرت إلى
النظام السابق كان يُنظر إلى المعاق بصورته
المباشرة، الضمان الاجتماعي فكرته العامة ليستمعالجة الحيثيات
فليست الفكرة من الضمان الاجتماعي هي تقديم
دعم الإعاقة أو تقديم دعم
لليتيم، لأنه في برامج أخرى معنية بهذه
الحالات، في برنامج التأهيل الشامل هذا معنى
بحالات الإعاقة، وغيرها من البرامج الكثيرة
الموجودة في السعودية، بينما الضمان الاجتماعي
هو يستهدف شيء آخر، يستهدف تلبية احتياجات
الأساسية للأسرة، فهو يحاول أن يجعل هذه
الأسرة قادرة على توفير وتلبية احتياجاتها
الأساسية بصورة كاملة، لأجل أن أصل إلى هذا الأمر
لابد أن أنظر إلى الأسرة بمجموعها الكامل
فاليوم إذا كان عندي أسرة
ما عندها أي حيثية من الحيثيات، يعني ليست أسرة
فيها أيتام، وليست أسرة فيها إعاقة
وليس فيها كبير سن، ولكن هذه الأسره دخلها منخفض
في السابق كانت هذه الأسره غير مستحقة للضمان
اليوم الأسرة...
ما فيها الحالات المذكورة
اليوم هذه الأسرة أصبحت مستحقة للضمان الإجتماعي
في السابق لو كان رب الأسره موظف ما
كنا نستطيع أن يكون من ضمن الأسر المستفيدة
اليوم أصبح الشخص قد يكون موظف ومع ذلك
مستحق للضمان الاجتماعي، مدام أنه دخل هذه
الأسرة ما يلبي احتياجات الأساسية لهذه الأسرة
وهذه تعتبر أول اختلاف بين نظام السابق
والنظام الحالي، بأنه كان مصمم لحالات
مطلقة أو أرملاء أو كبير سن أو معاق
اليوم صار مُصمم لاحتياج لم يلبى داخل الأسرة
بالضبط
بغض النظر عن تصنيفك قد تكون ما تنطبق عليك
كل هذا، ولكنك مستحق للدعم
تمام
أيضًا من الاختلافات الظاهر أنه تحول من الفرد
إلى الأسرة ولّا لا؟
صحح لنا الاختلاف هذا؟
اليوم الضمان الاجتماعي يستهدف الأسرة بصورة
كاملة، يمكن أنا ذكرت قبل شوي أنه اليوم
احنا ننظر لدخل الأسرة بشكلها الكاملن فأنت على
أساس تنظر الدخل الكلي لابد أنك تُضيف في طلبك
كافة الأفراد اللي يقومون في ذات المسكن
هل اليوم موجود عندنا أفراد في الضمان
الاجتماعي؟ نعم موجود تسجيل
لحالات أفراد في الضمان الإجتماعي
ولكن يجب أن يكون هؤلاء الأفراد مستقلين السكن
إذا كان المسكن يحتوي على مجموعة أفراد، فلا بدّ أن
يكون جميع هؤلاء الأفراد في ذات المسكن
في الطلب الواحد، على أساس أستطيع أحقق مجموعة من الأشياء
اليوم أنا لابد أن يكون في عندي
تكامل من أفراد المجتمع على أساس بالفعل
أحقق مجتمعي الحيوي، لابد أن يكون عندي أن أفراد
المنزل الواحد ما بينهم تكامل وتعاون
في توفير الاحتياجات الأساسية لهذه الأسرة
خلني أضرب لك مثال، اليوم إذا احنا ننظر
لدعم الغذاء، وكذلك دعم الكهرباء، وكذلك
المسكن وغيرها من الجزئيات اللي تخص الأسرة
بصورة كاملة، هذه الأشياء ما يختص فيها فرد
بصورة مستقلة عن بقية الأفراد الموجودة في المسكن
لذلك لابد أني على أساس أعطي الدعم لهذه الأشياء
أني أنظر إلى الأسرة بصورتها الكاملة
وبالمناسبة كلما زاد أفراد الأسرة في الطلب
الواحد، كلما ارتفع المعاش لهذه الأسرة
وكذلك ارتفع معها البرامج المساندة لأنه
ينظر إلى هؤلاء الأفراد بصورة كاملة
ما زلنا نحاول نفهم احنا من هم المستحقين بعدين
راح ندخل على أيش تقدمون لهم، بس في جزئية الأسرة
كثير من الرسائل اللي جاءتنا ناس يتسألون على مفهوم
تحويل الدعم من فرد إلى أسرة لأنه أصبح يمثل
عبء واحدة من الحالات اللي أرسلت أنه عندنا
شخص عنده إعاقة في البيت كان يحصل على
الضمان حاليًّا أوقف الضمان لأنه لا يستطيع
أن يكون مستقل هو حالة إعاقة يجب أن نعيله
كأنكم تقولون إرموه لكي يأخذ دعم بينما
نحفز أننا محتوينا ما نودينه في مركز معين
ورامين مسؤوليته على الدولة احنا كأسرة نقوم
بإعالته فليش نعاقب بإيقاف الضمان
رغم أنه هو معاق ويستحق هذا الرعاية
اليوم يمكن أن تتذكر معي حديثنا في بداية
الحلقة مررنا على الجزئية بصورة طفيفة اليوم
الوزارة تسعى بصورة كاملة إلى الدخول مع هذه
الأسر والأخذ بيدها إلى الوصول إلى
المكان الصحيح عندما يوجد لدي
فرد معاق في أسرة من الأسر فإن الوزارة
تتدخل بصورة كاملة وتُقدم لها الدعم المناسب
لهذه الحالة في اليوم على طول الحالة
الإعاقة الوزارة تُقدم دعم اسمه دعم
التأهيل الشامل فمباشرة الوزارة ما هو
هذا الدعم؟
هذا دعم كامل يقدم للمستفيدين
من الحالة الإعاقة والوزارة تنظر إلى
الإعاقة حتى تُقدم لها
الدعم يتصل بالجانب الطبي وتلتزم ببعض
الأدوات المساندة مثل الكراسي المتحركة مثل
العكاز وغيرها
من الأشياء أو الأدوات اللي يستفيد منها
المعاق اليوم عندما ننظر للضمان كفكرة
الضمان ينظر إلى تلبية أحجاة الأساسية
بينما اليوم عندما نتكلم عن حالات الإعاقة،
فاحنا نتكلم عن حالة تحتاج بالفعل إلى الأخذ
بيدها للمساعدة في تسهيل الحياة
لهذا الإنسان اليوم
المعاق يحتاج إلى أشياء كثيرة يحتاج إلى
كرسي متحرك في حال كانت العاقة في القدمين
يحتاج
إلى أغذية معينة أو خاصة لحالة العاقة يحتاج
إلى أشياء متعددة لحالتها وهذه كلها تلبيها
الوزارة؟ كلها تلبيها الوزارة من خلال
التأهيل الشامل لهؤلاء الأفراد فأنا أقول
اليوم، الفكرة العامة للدعم أصبحت
تنظر إلى المستفيد بعين أوسع
وتُقدم الرعاية بصورة أكبر فليس من الصحيح أن
اليوم أقول للشخص الذي يحتاج إعاقة
يحتاج كرسية أو شيء آخر أن أصرف لك ضمان
اجتماعي بينما المفترض أن أقول له تعال أنا
أساعدك في حالة الإعاقة
ويقدم لك الدعم بصورة كاملة حتى في
المراكز التابعة للوزارة في بعض
الزملاء المختصين بالجانب الطبي وتقديم
الرعاية وغيرها أيضًا في بعض المراكز
الإيوائية الخاصة بحالات
الإعاقة لذلك الوزارة في هذا الجزء تركز
بصورة كاملة إلا أنه لا يمكن أن تترك هذا
المعاق وإنما تُقدم لها
الدعم ولكن من مكانها الصحيح
من تطور البناء إلى أناقة التصميم ورفاهية
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنية مبتكرة
ومستدامة مع شركة صفا للاستثمار
المزيد في وصف الحلقة
ترجمة وصفة نانسي قنقر حلقة
فجر كل يوم نتكلم فيها عن جديد العالم من
أحداث وأخبار ونشرح حظاً من سياقها من
تاريخها التطورها كل يوم بيومة وكل خبر
بطيء بودكاست الفجر متوفر على جميع
منصات البودكاست اشترك وتابع الجديد
موضوع التقديم على الاستحقاق أيش الآلية
و المسار اللي يقدم فيه المستحق أو الذي
يرغب في استفادة من الضمان؟ وما معنى
ما تتكلمون عنه توافقون أو ترفضون؟
اليوم، ربما ذكرت لك أنه من المبادرات
على أساس أن نصل إلى التحول إلى نقل
وهو توفير منصة اليوم، الوزارة وفرت منصة
منصة الدعم والحماية الاجتماعية هذه المنصة
رقمية بالكامل في مسكنك، تستطيع أن تدخل على
الوزارة، وتبدأ الخطوات من الأولى إلى الخطوة
الأخيرة إلى وصول المعاش
إلى المستفيد بصورة كاملة
وأنت في بيتك
وأنت في بيتك بدون ما تحتاج تحرك ولا شيء بل
أزيدك، اليوم المشهد الضماني على أساس تأخذ
تعريف نحتاج أيضًا تأخذه
من من بيتك ومن جوالك
وشو هذا المشهد الضماني لم يعرف
اليوم، الضماني يستطيع الحصول على تعريف بأن
هذا الشخص مستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي وهو
مستحق ومواهل من الضمان الاجتماعي
ويحتاجه في عدد من الخدمات
أيش تفيده هذه؟
يستفيد منها في بعض الخدمات الأخرى مثل عندك
اليوم في الخدمات القضائية
التكاليف القضائية الضمانيين معفين من هذا
الشرط فوجود المشهد الضماني يساعدك في إثبات
أن هذا الشخص ضماني
وبالتالي مستحق لهذا الخدمة
فكل رحلة التقديم اليوم صارت مؤتمة
ينجزها الشخص من بيته أو من مكانه
بالكامل أيش معايير القبول والرفض؟
اليوم خليني ممكن من المناسب أن أعطيك
الرحلة على أساس تكون الصورة واضحة اليوم
المفترض بالمستفيد أن يدخل على منصة الدعم
والحماية الاجتماعية ويختار
البرنامج الخاص فيه وهو برنامج الضمان
الاجتماعي يبدأ المستفيد بداية بتعبئة الملف
الموحد الملف الموحد هذا يأخذ صورة كاملة عن
المستفيد على أساس يساعده في جميع الدعوم
اللي ستتوفر على المنصة للمستفيد في أي حالة
من الحالات اللي يكون عليها
بيانات السكن ، بيانات الدخل ، بيانات
التابعين وغيرهم
بعد ذلك يدخل عندنا بيانات الاهلية الأولية
وهذه تتم للمستفيد خلال الفترة الأولى تتحقق
المنصة بصورة سريعة جدًّا هل المستفيد مستحق
بحيث يكمل الطلب أو لا يكمل الطلب إذا
البيانات مكتملة وصحيح الادخال
يتحول مباشرة إلى أهلية
هنا لحظة، وما المعايير اللي يبين
عليها الأهلية هل يستحق أم لا؟
هذه فقط بيانات الادخال إذا كان أكمل
البيانات يدخل معنا إلى الأهلية نسميها
أهلية شهرية وهذه تصدل المستفيد
كل شهر الوزارة
تعلن نتائج الأهلية في تاريخ يعني تراوح ما
بين 26 إلى 28 في هذا الفترة
تعلن نتائج الأهلية نتائج الأهلية
تقوم على عدد من توفر عدد من المعايير.
الشرط الأول أنه يكون هذا المستفيد وهذا
الشرط الأساسي عندنا أمانةً اللي هو أن يكون
هذه الأسرة دخلها ما يلبي احتياجاتها
الأساسية بمعنى أن الدخل للأسرة منخفض متى
كان مجموع دخل الأسرة منخفض
أن تلبي احتياجات الأساسية
هذيك الأسرة مستحقاً هل فيه رقم ثابت؟
نعم، احنا اليوم نقول كم هو الحد المانع
للأسرة؟ ننظر إلى أفراد الأسرة نجمعهم مع
بعض ونقول العائل يُعطى مبلغ له مبلغ الدعم
ريال والتابعين كل تابع 660 ريال نضرب هذه
الأعداد ثم نجمعها مع بعض ونحدد الحد المانع
للأسرة ولكن هل كل دخل أعتبره دخل كامل ومن
ثم أعتبر أن هذا الدخل يمنعني من
الدخول للضمان الاجتماعي الجواب لا
سعفوني برهينة لا أفهم تلوش الحد اللي
تقولون لم يوصل لهذا الحد فهو يعتبر
احتياجاته غير مغطات
اليوم الحد ليس حد ثابت للجميع إنما الحد
يتغير بعدد أفراد الأسرة كلما زاد أفراد
الأسرة كلما ارتفع الحد وكلما انخفض عدد
أفراد الأسرة انخفض معي الحد فأنا أعطيك على
سبيل المثال إذا عندنا أسرة مكونة مثلًا من
شخص واحد فإن الحد المانع لها 1320
ريال إذا كانت الأسرة مكونة من شخصين فإنه
سيكون 1320 بالإضافة إلى 660
إذا كان عندي أسرة مكونة من ثلاث أشخاص فإنه
1320 بإضافة إلى 1260 ستميع ستين وستمية
ستين عفواً 1320 فأنت ستجمع الأرقام وتظهر
حد المانع لكل أسرة ببناءً عنها القاعدة
أرجع للنقطة اللي استطرت فيها وهي نقطة أنه
هل أي دخل أنا أعتبره دخل مانع وأحتسبه بس
عفوا ناسي بنقصه بس عشان هذه مره مهمة فهذا
هو الحد اللي تعتبرونه هو الحد الأدنى
لتحقيق الاحتياجات الأساسية
صحيح
أي أحد لم يحققه فهو مستحق الآن نتحدث عن
مداخل الأسرة بالضبط بل أن هذه هي الحد
اللي يقاس عليها مستوى دخل الأسرة بالضبط
تمام إذا حددنا الرقم وقلنا أنه اليوم الحد
لهذا الأسرة هو هذا الرقم
نقول يا أسرة عطيني ما هي دخولك على أساس
أعرف هل هذه الدخول من الدخول المعتبرة
بمعنى أنها هي المؤثرة على الحد المانع لهذه
الوسرى وحد الأدنى للاحتساب المعاش أو أنها
لا تزال تحت هذا الحد وبالتالي مستحقة لضمان
اليوم نفرق الدخل بين جزئيته
عندنا دخل نسميه الدخل المكتسب وعندنا الدخل
غير المكتسب وما الفرق بين الدخلين؟ الدخل
المكتسب هو الدخل الذي حصل عليه المستفيد
نتيجة عمل وجهد لنفترض الراتب الشهري حصل
على هذا الدخل نتيجة عمل وجهة بذلة ثم حصل
على هذا الدخل أيضًا الراتب التقاعدي هو
حقيقة صحيح بدون عمل الآن ولكن كان نتيجة
عمل وجهة في السابق هذه الدخول الوزارة تنظر
إلى 50% منها فقط فهي تخصم 50% كألم يكون
لنفترض شخص راتبه 5 ألاف نقول الراتب اللي
احنا ننظره 2500 فقط بينما
2500 المتبقية تعتمر كألّم تكون أيضًا إذا
كان دخل الأسرة في أي صورة من الصور لا
يتجاوز 2000 ريال فأنا أعتبره صفر مباشرة
كأنّه ما في عندي دخل كامل الجزء الثاني
اللي هو القسيم الثاني من أقسام الدخل وهو
الدخل غير المكتسب وهذا الدخل اللي حصل عليه
المستفيد نتيجة
بدون أي عمل أو جهة بدلها المستفيد هذه
الحالة نحسب الدخل كدخل كامل اليوم لما تيجي
عندي أسرة رب أسرة وكذلك عنده
تابعين زوجة وابن واحد فقط ودخلهم خمسة آلاف
لما أجي أناظر أقول هذا الدخل من وين جاء
فيكون راتب شهري على سبيل المثال أقول أنا
رح أخذ 2500 فقط أحط ال2500
عندي وبعدين أروح أناظر كم الحد المانع
الأسرة مكونة من ثلاثة أشخاص معناها عندي 1320
وكذلك 1320 ثانية اللي هي للتابعينن مجموعة
هذان الرقمان معناها أنت تتكلم عن 2640
إذًا الدخل أقل من الحد المانع الأسرة أصبحت
مستحقة الآن وتستفيد من معاش الضمان
الاجتماعي لكن لو كان الدخل أعلى فإن الأسرة
أصبحت تلبيح تجهيز الأساسية وما يخدمها
برنامج الضمان الاجتماعي وقد تخدمها
البرامج الأخرى مثل حساب المواطن وغيرها
وفي حال الاستحقاق أنا أخذ كامل مبلغ
وليس الفرق اللي يوصلني للحد المانع
هذا أيضًا جزئية مهمة الإشارة لها وهي أنه هل
اليوم بمجرد استحقاقك بمعنى لو افترضنا أن
عندي أسرة تستحق أقل من الحد المانع مثلًا
بمئة ريال وعندي أسرة مجموعة الدخل حقها صفر
هل أنا راح أساوي بينهم
بالمعاش؟ الجواب أنه لا راح تعطي الأسرة ما
يوصلها إلى الحد المعنى اليوم هل الدعم اللي
يقدم للأسرة هو فقط المعاش اللي ذكرناه
اللي هو 1320
الجواب لا، في برامج دعم إضافية فعندنا دعم
أقر مؤخرا وهو دعم الحليب، وهذا الدعم يقدم
للأطفال في الأسرة من عمر سنتين إلى أقل
يقدم لهم دعم الحليب بصورة كاملة ويقدم بشكل
شهري إذا تجاوز ما برامج الدعم هذا هو دعم
نقدي يضاف إلى دعم معاش الضمان الاجتماعي
أيضًا عندنا دعم خاص بالكهرباء ودعم خاص
بالغذاء وفيه دعم للفرش
والتأثير ففي برامج كثيرة
دعم الكهرباء عبارة عن خصم في سعر الكهرباء؟
أيضًا هي مبالغ إضافية تضاف على
ودعم الغذاء؟
جميع هذه الدعوم تقدم
نقدية فيه دعم أيضًا للحقيبة المدرسية والزي
المدرسي هذه تُقدم بداية كل فصل دراسي
للطلاب في المدارس فالدعوم
متنوعة ولذلك احنا ممكن ذكرنا في البداية
انه اليوم معاش الضمان الاجتماعي ليس فقط
مجرد المعاش الضماني أو المعاش الاساسي
وإنما في أيضًا
برامج مساندة تدعم هذا الرقم الأساسي
اليوم كم نستطيع أن نقول عدد
المستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي؟
أحد الجزئيات المهمة اللي أشار لها
قبل أن ندخل على سؤالك وهو هل
الدعوم اليوم تُقدم للأسر بشكلها الكامل؟ أو
كيف نقدم الدعم؟ اليوم الضمان الاجتماعي
أشارنا قبل قليل إلى أنه أصبح ينظر إلى
الأسرة بصورتها الكاملة فلما تنظر إلى
الأسرة بصورة كاملة بكافة أفرادها فأنت
تتكلم عن مجموعة الأفراد الموجودين في
المسكن الواحد وتُقدم لهم الدعم الضماني.
الضمان ينظر إلى كل التفاصيل
الموجودة في الأسرة.
فهو يساعد الطلاب على
التجهيزات الخاصة بالمدارس من خلال
الدعم الخاص بالحقيبة والزي المدرسي.
يساعد حتى في
دفع وصوم اختبارات قياس في الوصول عند مراحل
اختبار القياس وغيرها من الاحتياجات اللي
تساعد هذه الأسر بمجموعة كامل إلى الوصول
إلى التلبية الحجة الأساسية وتصبح هذه الأسر
قادرة على التحول إلى أسر منتجة
ومكتفية بصورة كاملة
فما في عندنا رقم معين نقدر نحسبه
أو نعرفه عن المستفيدين من الضمان؟
هو الضمان الاجتماعي
يتنوّع مثلما ذكرت قبل قليل احنا اليوم
الضمان لما تطور واصبح عندنا منصة رقمية
أصبح في تعاون ربط الكتروني مع عدد من
الجهات الحكومية فأصبحت الوزارة
تحدث البيانات الموجودة عن المستفيدين بشكل
شهري حتى تتأكد من وصول هذا المبلغ للأسر
المستحقة فعلًا منه لذلك احنا عندنا كل شهر
دورة أهلية تتحقق من مدى انطباق الاشتراطات
لاستحقاق هذه الأسر ولذلك احنا اليوم لما
ننظر إلى الضمان الاجتماعي نجده متغير كل
شهر يتغير عن الشهر الذي يليه أو الشهر الذي
السابق له في أشخاص يدخلون جدد وهناك
أشخاص يخرجون وعندنا مصدر كبير جدًّا يخرج منه
عدد كبير من المستفدين من الضمان الاجتماعي
وهو النقطة الأساسية اللي ركزنا عليها في
البداية من ضمن مستهدفات الرؤية اللي هي
التمكين فأنت اليوم تتكلم عن تمكين هذه
الأسر حتى تصبح هذه الأسر
مستغنية عن دعم الضمان الاجتماعي
هذا يوجد فيها جزئية مهمة في موضوع التمكين
لكنني أريد أن أقفل موضوع الاستحقاق
من ضمن الأسئلة اللي جاءتنا
انزعاج شوي من بعض اشتراطات الاستحقاق اللي
أصبحت تعيق بعض المستفيدين على سبيل المثال
اشتراط عقد أجار
بعضهم يقول احنا ساكنين في مساكن
ما فيها عقود أجار
بالشكل الجديد منصة إيجار وإلى آخره فهذا
يتحرمنا من الاستفادة ليش شرط عقد الإيجار
بدل ما كان سابقاً موضوع فاتورة
الكهرباء أو عداد الكهرباء
اليوم الأوامر الكريمة تقول فيما يتعلق في
حال وجود إيجار الاعتماد هو على منصة إيجار
وهذه فيها أوامر كريمة
على أساس أنه يكون في حوكمة جيدة لهذه
العقود وضبطها
اليوم هل الضمان الإجتماعي يشترط
تقديم عقد الإيجار بصورة مطلقة الجواب هو
هذه المعلومة قد ما تكون دقيقة اليوم الأسرة
الضمان الاجتماعي لا يطلب منهم إثبات السكن
متى يطلب إثبات السكن؟ إذا كان هذا الفرد
الوحيد مستقل عن هذه الأسرة فمتى ما كان هذا
الشخص كمفرد يستقل عن هذه الأسرة يجب أن
يثبت أنه بالفعل لم يعد من ضمن هذا الكيان
الكامل وهو كيان الأسرة بصورته الكاملة
لذلك اليوم احنا لما نطلب
إذا كانت الأسرة في بيت شعبي
ما هو ضمن منصة «إيجار» المالك ما هو حاطه
في منصة «إيجار» أيش الحل معهم؟
الضمان اجتماعي اليوم ما يشترط اثبات
السكن لهذه الأسرة المكونة من مجموعة
الالأفراد بصورته الكاملة ما يشترط النظام
تقديم إثبات السكن لهذه الأسرة فهو اشتراط
السكن خاص فقط بالأفراد المستقلين
اللي يستقلون عن أسرهم، لأنه أنت اليوم
لم تعد ضمن هذا الكيان فلا بد من إثبات
لمنع التلاعب في أن واحد يقول أحد أنه مستقل وهو فعليًّا ما هو مستقل
هذا الهدف؟
صحيح لأن اليوم دعمك اليوم هو دعم للأسرة
فليس من الصحيح أن يكون الدعم مضاعف وهناك
أسر أخرى مستحقة
يجب أن تستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي، فاليوم
أنا أدعم مثلًا الكهرباء وهو مدام مازال
موجود في ذات الأسرة فالفاتورة واحدة ليس من
الصحيح أن يكون في دعمين
لذات الغرض وفي أسر أخرى متقدمة هي مستحقة
لهذا الدعم، وليس من الصحيح أن يكون
الدعم موجه إلى هذه الأسرة بصورة مضاعفة
بينما الأسر الأخرى
قد تكون هي الأكثر حاجة لهذا الدعم
وليوم ما هو مصدر أموال الضمان
اللي تصرف على المستحقين؟
مصدر الأموال الضمان الاجتماعي هي ثلاث
مصادر أشارت لها المادة ثلاثة وعشرين من نظام الضمان
الاجتماعي أشارت إلى أن مصادر الضمان الاجتماعي ثلاثة
الأولى الزكاة اللي تجبيها الدولة
وكذلك الهبات والنفقات والصدقات اللي تُقدم إلى
الزكاة، والثالث هي الدعم اللي تقدمه خزينة
الدولة إلى الضمان الاجتماعي
اليوم الزكاة تصرف بصورة كاملة تُصرف
اللي هي زكاة الشركات، وزكاة الأفراد
الزكاة بصورة عامة تُصرف للمستفدين الضمان
الاجتماعي، وما تقل عنه هذه القيمة يتم
دعمها من خلال دعم الدولة بصورة مباشرة
فالمستحقين ثابتة مصرفاتهم
يغطيها بشكل أساسي زكاة
اللي تجمعها هيئة الزكاة والدخل
والفرق أو العجز
الدولة هي اللي تدعمها حتى تغطيها النفقات
وهذا يحملكم صراحة مسؤولية كبيرة جدًّا في
إيصالها لمستحقينها لأن أحيانًا البعض يعني
يتوسع شوي في الاستفادة من الدعم الحكومي
بحكم أنه هذه البلد خيرها يعمل جميع وخيرها
دائمًا يصل لأبنائها فالناس يتساهلون في
الحصول على أنواع الدعم المختلفة
بس هنا احنا نتكلم على موضوع مختلف نتكلم على
زكاة زكاة شرعية
خرجت من أصحابها لأغراض محددة في الشرع لا
يمكن تجاوزها فهذا يحملكم مسؤولية إيصالها
للمستحقين ولذلك أفهم أنكم تضعون ضوابط
تتحررون فيها الدقة العالية
بس في نفس الوقت أحيانًا زيادة الحرص
تثقل على المحتاج المفترض أنه يُعان ولا
يُهان بعض الناس تكون من كثرة الزيارات أنه
أول زيارة واحدة في السنة
و يكفي الآن أربع زيارات في السنة وكل
زيارة فيها
الدخول التأكد السؤال بعض الحالات اللي فيها
مثلًا كبير سن فوق الستين سنة وعنده
إعاقة معينة ما راح يتغير، ما راح توصلوه
وتلاقوا عمره صار خمسين، ما راح توصلون وتلاقون
الرجل المبتورة نمت مرة ثانية، ففي حالات
واضح أنها لن تتغير أيش الحاجة من
تكرار الزيارات أربع مرات في
السنة بشكل يرهق بعض المستفيدين؟
الزيارات الميدانية اللي اليوم تتم
للمستفيدين ليس الغرض منها فقط جمع البيانات
والتحقق فقط إنما هذا أحد
الأعمال اللي يقوم بها الباحث الميداني ولكن
في خدمات كثيرة يقدمها الباحث الميداني
لهذه الأسر عند زيارته فمثلًا يساهم الباحث
الميداني في المساعدة في حال وجود حالات
تتطلب حماية اجتماعية أيضًا يساهم
في حال وجود حاجة شديدة لهذه الأسرة فأنه
يساعد في تحويل هذه الأسرة إلى ضمن مبادرة
اسمها مبادرة تفريج كربة، وهي مبادرة تقوم
الوزارة بالتدخل بصورة سريعة على هذه الأسرة
وتقديم عدد من الدعم المباشر
سواء كانت سلال غذائية أو غيرها.
أحيانًا تساهم
الزيارة في الاكتشاف عدد من الحالات اللي
تتطلب علاج طبي سواء
يعني علاج نفسي أو حاجة طبية لأحد أفراد هذه
الأسرة فالباحث الميداني هو شريك الأسرة
أو مساعد الأسرة في نقل ما لديهم من
احتياجات إلى الوزارة
أو حتى الوزارات الأخرى اللي تشارك الوزارة
في مساعدة لتجاوز
الحالة اللي موجودة عند هذه الوزارة الباحث
الميداني زيارته ليست فقط مجرد تدقيق أو أن
المعاق قد يكون تعافى نحن
نتمنى للجميع الشفاء والعافية.
ولكن فقط مجرد الاكتشاف
الحالة أو التلاعب الذي قد يكون موجود.
هذا جزء بسيط من زيارة الباحث.
إنما زيارة الباحث الهدف منها أعم وأشمل
فالباحث هو صديق للأسرة لنقل ما لديهم من
احتياجات وكذلك مساعدتهم
في تجاوز أي عقبة ممكن تجيهم اليوم
مصارف الحياة كثيرة
والأزمات اللي تمر فيها الأسر متنوعة
الباحث الميداني هو شريك الأسرة وصوت الأسرة
للوصول إلى الجهة المعنية لخدمتها سواء كانت
تتطلب حماية تتطلب جانب طبي
أي جانب من الجوانب وحتى الباحث الميداني من
ضمن المهام اللي لديه أن يساعد الأسرة في
تعريفها في بعض الاحتياجات اللي لديها على
سبيل المثال، أحيانًا يكون مثل ذكرنا أنه
إعفاء الضمانيين من التكاليف القضائية
قد يكون الضماني لا يعرف هذه المعلومة
فالباحث الميداني من واجبة أن يوصل هذه
المعلومة إلى الأسرة المستفيدة فهو شريك
الأسرة وليست المقصود من إثقال
كهل الأسرة بكثرة الزيارة
يعني أعتقد أنتم أبخص لكن أربع أو أثنين أو
واحد أدروا بالمناسب لكن يجيد أن يكون
في توافق بينكم وبين الأسر على
الألية اللي لا تثقلهم وتحقق الغاية اللي من
جهتكم مدى أنك تريت موضوع التلاعب
كيف تتعاملون مع حالة التلاعب وضعاف
النفوش اللي يسيون اشتغلال مثل هذه البرامج
بس إذا تسمح لي أرجع للجزئية السابقة اللي
هي كم عدد الزيارات الميدانية
الوزارة ما تزور أربع إنما النظام يقول الحد
الأدنى زيارة كل سنة فالوزارة حاليًّا تزور
مرة واحدة ولكن تستهدف إن شاء الله زيادة
العدد في حالات أرسلونا
أنه في أربع زيارات أحيانًا
الزيارة ممكن تتكرر إذا المستفيد قدم بيانات
إضافية فأنت اليوم إذا قدمت إنه صار عندك
إضافة أو صار عندك حاجة فإنه
يتم زيارة الأسرة من خلال الباحث الميداني
أو أحيانًا يكون
الأسرة حصل لها ضرف أثناء الزيارة فما حبت
استكمال رحلة الزيارة أو طلبت من الباحث
تأجيل الموعد فإنه يؤجل ولكن الزيارة
الكاملة اللي تمنقلها للنظام هي
زيارة واحدة في الوقت الحالي تمام،
موضوع التلاعب
موضوع التلاعب، اليوم احنا عندنا
نظام الضمان الاجتماعي يقدم دعم للمستفيدين
ويحرص أمانةً أن يكون قريب
من المستحق فعليًّا ومثلما ذكرت اليوم أموال
الزكاة هي أموال
معنية بالصيانة والحرص وأنها
مفترضة أن لا تصل إلى المستحق فعليًّا منها
في وجود حالة تلاعب أمانةً يحمل الوزارة
حمل كبير جدًّا أنه في البداية يجب توضيح
للمستفيد أنه هنا عندك حالة تلاعب والواجب
عليك إعادة هذه الأموال للوزارة لإعادة
صرفها للمستحقين وأشار
النظام في المادة عشرين إلى عدد من العقوبات من
بينها المتحايل للحصول على معاش الضمان
الاجتماعي ويتم تحويل هذه الحالات لجهة
الإختصاص الواردة في المادة واحد وعشرين وهي
النيابة العامة فهذه الصورة العامة
هل في حالات كثيرة من هنوع
وإلا محدودة أو إلا أيش رصدتوه؟
في حالات من حالات التلاعب
تقديم بعض المستلدات غير الصحيحة تقديم عقود
إيجار ليست حقيقية
وهذه الحالات تمت مشاركتها إلى جهة الاختصاص
ويجري العمل فيها كونها أحدى حالات موسيقى
من الأرقام اللي حكينا عنها أبو إبراهيم
يتضح أنه وهذا غرض نبيل
غرض البرنامج هو أنه يوفر حد الكفاف
لكنه لا يصنع حياة كريمة بالضرورة
وهنا يأتي الدور الآخر لكم بأنكم كيف
تمكنونهم لينتقلوا من حالة الكفاف إلى حالة
الحياة الكريمة اللي يكون فيها مستوى
الدخل أو مستوى المعيشة أفضل بكثير وهذا لن
يحدث بمزيد من الدعم بقدر ما نحدث بتمكين
هذا الإنسان من أن يكون
في وضع أفضل
والمثل الشهير لا تعطيني سمك أعلمني كيف
أصيب وماذا عن الدور اللي تقومون به
لتمكينهم من الوصول لمستويات أفضل
تساعدهم على أن يعيشوا الحياة أكثر كرامة
اليوم في جهد كبير من الوزارة يقام في
هذا الجزئي الذي ذكرته هو جزئية التمكين
الرؤية السعودية 2030 أشارت مثلما ذكرنا قبل
شوي في المستوى الثالث من ضمن أهدافها اللي
هي تمكين المستفيدين من خلال منظومة الخدمات
الاجتماعية لذلك الوزارة وضعت في عاتقها
حمل تحويل هؤلاء المستفيدين من أشخاص متلقين
للدعم فقط إلى أشخاص قادرين على العمل ومن
ثم رفع مستوى المعيشة وتحسين الدخل من خلال
العمل
فالوزارة أوجدت عدد من المبادرات وكذلك قسمت
العديد من الأعمال لهؤلاء المستفيدين
مثل المازالوا في المدارس، مثل الأشخاص
المعاقين يعاقة شديدة تمنع عن العمل هؤلاء
الأشخاص ما يدخلون معنا من ضمن
برامج التمكين يبقى عندنا الجزئين الأولين
وهو القادة للعمل والقابل للتأهيل وهؤلاء
الوزارة تحرص بشكل كبير إلى أن تأخذ بأيديهم
إلى العمل سواء كان من خلال برامج التدريبية
المنتهية بالتوظيف أو حتى التأهيل وكذلك
أيضًا البرامج في المشاريع الريادية
والاقتصادية
عندنا حقيقة عدد كبير من صور النجاح يعني
خليني أعطيك مثلًا بالأرقام
اليوم المحقق على مستوى التمكين الوزارة مكنت من 2017
430 ألف أسرة دخلت معها في برامج التمكين هؤلاء
كلهم دخلوا معنا في التمكين وأصبحوا أسرة
ممكنة الحصول على زيادة مستوى الدخل للأسرة
خرج من هذه القائمة 200 ألف أسرة استغنت
بشكل كامل عن الضمان الاجتماعي وأصبحت أسر
مكتفية بدخلها وعندنا عدد
من الحالات أو قصص النجاح
عندهم إجمال الضمانيين منهم 430 ألف
استفادوا من برامج التمكين
منها اللي استفادوا في 200 ألف
حتى استغنوا تماما عن الضمان وكان
المحقق للمملكة العربية السعودية في هذا
الجزء محقق عالي جدًّا
البنك الدولي زار السعودية وطلع على البيانات
الخاصة بهذا الأعداد وأشاد بدور السعودية
وحتى استشهد بالإجراءات
اللي تمت في السعودية بهذه الجزئية في عدد من
مقالاتها المنشورة
استفادت عدد من الدول الأخرى وزارت السعودية
وحاولت استنساخ التجربة عندنا مثلًا في مملكة
البحرين وفي الكويت عدد من الدول اللي
أصبحت تفد إلى السعودية وتحاول الاستفادة من
التجارة سوف أقوم بزيارة
التفاصيل وأفهم ما أقوم به بالضبط وما
أعطيته لهم حتى يستغنوا عن الضمان لأن بعض
الناس تخوف من أن يفقد هذا الدخل المضمون
مقابل دخل غير مضمون
فكثير بالنسبة لهم يعتبر هذا حاجز
خليني أقول لك مثلًا
كجزء من أجزاء التمكينة، اليوم عندنا أجزاء
التمكين كثيرة من بينها الجزء الخاص
بالتوظيف فالوزارة تعمل على تقديم الدورات
والتدريب وتأهيل المستفيد إلى أن ينتهي بهذه
المطاف إلى الحصول على فرصة وظيفية من خلال
شركاء الوزارة والدخول في
العمل والتكسب والحصول على الرزق من هذا
المسار أيضًا مسار يخص الأعمال الريادية والإنتياجية
والأعمال الاقتصادية، وهنا تُقدم الوزارة دعم
مالي وكذلك دعم غير مالي بالمناسبة
في مجال التمكين الوزارة وقعت أكثر من 300
اتفاقية مع عدد كبير جدًّا من
الجهات الحكومية، وكذلك الشركات في القطاع
الخاص والمؤسسات الجمعيات الخيرية وعقدت
معها عدد من الاتفاقيات
اللي تخدم مستفيدي الضمان بصورة مباشرة
وكذلك الجزء الخاص بالتمكين
أيضًا حاولت أن توجد نقطة تواصل والتقامة بين
أصحاب العمل ومستفيدي الضمان الاجتماعي
فأنشأت وأقامت أكثر من 156
ملتقة للتمكين وموزعة في كافة مناطق السعودية
في هذه الملتقيات نزل العديد
من فرص التوظيف والتحق فيها كثير من
المستفيدين خليني أقول لك احنا قمنا بتجربة
أو قياس لكي نرى مدى الجهد الذي يبذل.
نظرنا للممكنين
في 2019 وأخذنا منهم ثلاثة وعشرين ألف حالة فقلنا نأخذ
هذه العدد ونحاول أن نرى في عام 2022 ما
الذي حدث عليهم مر عليهم من عام 2019 وكذلك
عام 2021 وعام 2022 إلى نهايتها
فدعوني أرى ما الذي حدث على
الضمانيين في هذه الحالة
دخلنا على هؤلاء الأفراد ونظرنا إلى أين
وصلنا ولقينا أن نسبة 97.3%
ما يزالون في أعمالهم
و لم ينقطعوا عن العمل وهذه تعتبر نسبة
عالية جدًّا في مجال الأعمال وسوق العمل
بالإضافة إلى أن نسبة خمسة وسبعين من هذه القائمة أصبح عندها قفزات
عالية جدًّا في الرواتب والمتبقين
أصبحت في ارتفاعات، ولكن ارتفاعات أقل من
النسبة الأولى دعوني أقول لك بالمناسبة كان
عندنا أحد المستفيدين
في الضمان الاجتماعي عندما دخل في مسار
التمكين من هذه القائمة
كان الدخل من خلال الوظيفة
اللي التحق فيها مرتبها 5500 ، اليوم الراتب
الشهري له ثلاثة وأربعين ألف ريال بشكل شهري، ففي قفزة
عالية جدًّا التمكين من خلال المسار الاقتصادي
في نشاط عالي كان عندنا أحد المستفيدات
وهي المستفيدة سحر اسمها هذه المستفيدة
دخلت معنا في
الضمان الاجتماعي وبدأت من خلال
مسار التمكين الاقتصادي
فإنشئنا معها مشروع وقمنا بعمل دراسة جدوى
وساعدناها من الجانب المالي من خلال شركائنا
ودخلت في مجال المقاصف المدرسية
اليوم أصبح عندها مطعم اسمه حياكم النسائي
في المنطقة الغربية وهذه دعوة لزيارتها
العمل كبير جدًّا ويعني المطعم يعتبر كبير جدًّا
ومصدر دخل عالي للأسرة ففي تطور عالي جدًّا في
هذا المجال لذلك جاءت الإشادة من البنك
الدولي في هذه الجزئية في محلها وحاولوا
بالفعل محاولة السنساخة للصورة والتجربة
الموجودة في السعودية لكثير من
الدول اللي بينها وبينهم تعامل
وكيف يعني لو في أحد من المستفيدين من
الضمان يسمعنا الآن كيف يستفيد من مثل هذه
البرامج؟ وماذا الطريقة؟ وماذا الآلية؟
احنا يمكن ذكرت في البداية أنه احنا أول ما
يجي المستفيد نبدأ تصنيفه فإذا المستفيد من
ضمن الفئتين
المستهدفة بالتمكين وهي فئة القادر على
العمل والقابل للتعهيل
الوزارة تأخذ هذه القائمة بصورة تدريجية
ولكن الوزارة وضعت على عاتقها أنه يجب أن
أمر على جميع المستفيدين القابلين أفهم
هم الذين يستطيعون التواصل معكم
وأنتم تتواصلون مع المستحقين
صحيح، الوزارة تطلب من المستفيد إثبات جديدة
في البحث عن العمل فتساعد في التسجيل في
منصات التوظيف
مثل منصة الموارد البشرية هدف وغيرها من
المنصات وتلزم الوزارة المستفيد بأنه يسجل
على أساس تساعد بالفعل إلى التحول إلى شخص
منتج ولبنة بناء في المجتمع وهذه كانت من
البركات اللي جاءت
في النظام الجديد وفق رؤية
أنه اليوم المستفيد ليس فقط مجرد متلقي
للدعم وليس فقط مجرد متلقي للدعم إنما هو
شخص يجب أن يكون شخص
منتج ويتم الاستفادة منه
فعليًّا لأسرة ولمجتمعه بصورة كاملة
ولو بسألنا عن الأرقام بشكل عام
أنت في موضوع التوظيف كم اللي
فعلًا وظفتوهم في السنة الماضية؟
في سنة 2023 احنا تجاوزنا إلى 100 ألف
رقم يعتبر عالي جدًّا فيما يتعلق بالتمكين
واحنا نستهدف أمانةً كل سنة نزيد عن السنة
اللي بعدها وهذا الحمد لله قاعد نحققها
لما ننظر مؤشر الهدف
الذكرته من أهداف الرؤية وهو هدف 2.6.4
تمكين المستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي من
خلال منظومة الخدمات الاجتماعية
حققنا وفق مركز أداء
النسبة والمستهدف وزدنا عليها كذلك
اليوم احنا وصلنا نسبة 32% وهي نسبة تعتبر عالية
فهي أكثر من 100 ألف وظيفة
صحيح
وإذا اعتبرنا اللي صار في 2019
إن شاء الله راح يستمر
فـ 97% من اللي توظفوا في 2019 استمروا في
وظائفهم
فهذه ودنا هنا رسالة للأشخاص اللي لسه عندهم
حاجز، ولا يلامون هم أشخاص نشؤوا وكبروا على
مبدأ أنه هذا الضمان من إسمه ضمان شيء مضمون
ما أبغى أخاطر وأروح أخذ وظيفة
الوظيفة ممكن تنهي خدماتي، وأكون فوّت المضمون
مقابل الغير مضمون أيش رسالتك لهؤلاء؟
أنا مهم أن المستفيد يصل إلى معلومة
أساسية بشكل عالي جدًّا اليوم الضمان
الاجتماعي هو صديق لهذه الأسر، وهو شريك معها
في التحول إلى الإنتاج والبناء ورفع المستوى المعيشي
اليوم الضمان الاجتماعي لا يمكن أنه يحول الشخص
أويساعد الشخص في الوصول إلى وظيفة ثم
يتركه بصورة كاملة، إنما هو يستمر
في توفير الفرصة، وكذلك السعي إلى تحفيز هذا
الأسرة في زيادة الدخل، لو افترضنا أنه اليوم
حصل هذا المستفيد على الدخل من الوظيفة
هل راح يتوقف عنه الضمان الاجتماعي بصورة
كاملة؟ الجواب لا، إنما الضمان الاجتماعي
مثلما ذكرنا قاعدة الأساسية هي تجاوز الحد
المانع إذا كان الدخل من الوظيفة أعلى من الضمان الاجتماعي
فهو لا شك أفضل من الضمان الاجتماعي، وبالتالي
أصبحت الأسرة مستغنية عن الضمان الاجتماعي
سابقًا كان أول ما يتوظف يوقف...
الضمان الاجتماعي نعم، اليوم ننظر إلى
الدخل بصورة كاملة أنت موظف ودخلك
ملخفض أنت مستحق للضمان الاجتماعي
بس ما فيه راتب أقل من 1300؟ يعني...
هي فرضية غير واقعية
احنا نتكلم عن ليس الفرد بصورة واحدة
لما نتكلم عن الوظيفة فنتكلم عن الأسرة مثلما ذكرنا
لو افترضنا أسرة مكونة من خمسة أشخاص
أو ستة أشخاص فليس...
الحد الأدنى للاحتساب المعاشي 1300 إنما هو
يصعد مع الأسرة بالإضافة إلى أنه الراتب هذا
نأخذ منه 50% فقط كاحتساب فأنت تتكلم  عن رقم
أقل بكثير، فاليوم أنت ممكن تكون ضماني وفي
نفس الوقت على رأس العمل فهذا أمر إضافة إلى
وجود الضمان الاجتماعي، هو وجود مصدر
دخل آخر، وهو مصدر الوظيفة
ودي أبو إبراهيم أمر على مجموعة من أسئلة
الاصدقاء اللي أكرمونا فيها، هنا في سؤال احنا
عرجنا عليه شوي بس ممكن أخذ تعليقك عليه
هذا يقول نظام الضمان يشجِّع
على تجنب التوظيف لأنه ينهي الضمان
فصار فيه مفهوم اسمه توريث الضمان
الأب يمنع عياله من العمل حتى ما ينقطع الضمان
ليش ما يكون فيه تحفيز للتوظيف بمعنى
إذا توظفت ثلاثة شهور خلال فترة التجربة ما
ينقطع الضمان إلى آخره من سياسات تحفز على
عدم انقطاع الضمان وربطها بأن يصير عندي
دخل فأنا حتى لو توظفت بستة ألاف أو سبعة ألاف
ليش توقفونها فورًا؟ خلني أتجاوز فترة
التجربة، أطمئن وأرتاح
وبعدها أوقفوها أيش رأيك؟
يمكن أنا قلت قبل شوي أن الضمان الاجتماعي هو صديق الأسرة
فهو مع الأسرة
مادامت هذه الأسرة موجودة، اليوم لو افترضنا
أن أسرة عندنا أصبحت غير مستحقة من الضمان الاجتماعي
لأي سبب من الأسباب، ثم بعد ذلك
عادت الأسرة، وأصبحت مستحقة للضمان الاجتماعي
الضمان الاجتماعي يستقبل هذه الأسرة
فاحنا اليوم نقول
يعني طلعت مو معناه أنه انتهت العلاقة
مو معناه أنه انتهت العلاقة بالضبط
أنه متى ما نخفض دخل الأسرة...
لا سمح الله، لو انتهى عملك فأنت تقدرالرجوع
ولذلك حتى من جانب التمكين الضمان الاجتماعي
يستمر مع المستفيد من خدمات الضمان الاجتماعي
في الدعم وعندنا برنامج خاص نسميه برنامج إدارة الحالة
فاحنا نُساعد هذا المستفيد حتى بعد خروجه
من الضمان الاجتماعي
مثلًا في دراسة الجدوى نساعده حتى في توفير
الخدمات المالية، وغير المالية في الأنشطة
التجارية، وكذلك نساعده في الترقي
في أعماله الوظيفية، ومساعدته كيف يستطيع
يطور من نفسها حتى يكون بالفعل
مطمئن ومستقر بصورة كاملة من وظيفته الجديدة
في أسئلة كثيرة من السيدات تحديدًا من السيدات
اللي في سن العمل أنه ليش تجبرونا على العمل
واحنا ما عندنا عائل للأطفال
وراعي في البيت غيرنا، يعني في حالات كثيرة
المرأة صحيح أنها في سن عمل بس هي غير قادرة
على العمل، كيف تتعاملون مع الحالات هذه؟
يمكن احنا ذكرنا في البداية أن الضمان
الاجتماعي أول ما تدخل يقسِّم الحالات إلى
مستفيد قابل للتأهيل، وقابل للعمل، وغير قابل
للعمل، الغير القادر على العمل مجموعة أشخاص
من بينهم المعاق إعاقة شديدة وكبيرة السن والمرأة
التي لديها أبناء تحت السن إثنا عشر سنة
تحت إثنا عشر سنة
هذه غير مستهدفة عندنا في البرامج التمكين
إلّّا في حال أن الأسرة كانت هي من تطلب العمل
أو الاتحاق ببرامج التمكين
فالضمان الاجتماعي ممكن يساعدها في توفير
ما يناسب حالتها
ممتاز
يخدمها في هذا الجانب
فترى من هذا الجانب
نعم ترى بصورة كاملة
سؤال كثير تكرر المقطوعة السنوية
أيش  المقطوعة السنوية وليش توقفت؟
الضمان الاجتماعي
ذكرنا في مراحل التحول اللي صار في الضمان
الاجتماعي أصبح في نقلات كثيرة
مثلما ذكرنا أن السقف في الضمان السابق كان
واحد وثلاثين ألف ريال للأسرة في حدها الأعلى اليوم
نتكلم عن ستين ألف ريال للأسرة وكذلك
برامج مساندة قد تصل إلى أربعة غشر ألف ريال للأسرة
في حدها العالى فأصبحت اليوم المساعدة
مندمجة ضمن الدعم الأساسي لأن اليوم أنت
رفعت الدعم الأساسي بصورة عالية جدًّا للأسرة
وأصبحت مستمرة مع المستفيد طول السنة يعني
على كل الأشهر وليست تصرف مرة
واحدة لأسرة يعني لحالة هل
كانت تصرف في رمضان أو شيء لكده؟
ما زالت الدعم الكريم يصل في شهر رمضان
مكرمة أعلنت السنة الماضية وكذلك السنوات
السابقة لها وهذا الدعم يقدم من المقام
الكريم يعني لالتماس حاجة ولتلمس حاجة
المقطوعة هي اللي مرة وحدة وهذه انتهت
وصارت ضمن الدعم بشكله الجديد
صحيح هي اليوم دُمجت هذه المساعدة مع الدعم الأساسي
فرفع الدعم الأساسي بصورة كاملة للأسرة
سواءً كان الدعم البرامج المساندة أو حتى
الدعم الأساسي اللي هو الـ 1320
يعني خليني أعطيك على سبيل المثال في
القفزات اللي حصلت، لما نتكلم مثلًا في
النظام السابق عن التابع، التابع كان يحصل
على 280 ريال اليوم أنت تتكلم عن 660
فأنت تتكلم عن ثلاثة أضعاف لما تنظر إلى
مجموعة هذا الرقم، ونضربه في إثنا عشر شهر
في عدد التابعين الموجودين في الأسرة فأنت
تتكلم عن رقم يتجاوز المساعدة المقطوعة
بشكل كبير جدًّا، دُمجت مع الضمان وأصبح الثابتة
وليست مؤقتة، وأصبح الدعم كامل للأسرة ومستمر
في شكاوي كثير على تجربة التقديم
يعني شكرًا لكم حولتها إلى خدمة رقمية
لكن كثير من المستفيدين هم ليسوا في أحسن حالاتهم
سواء كبير سن، ولّا صاحب إعاقة
هذولي حسب سؤال السائل أنهم يعانون كثيرا
ومطلوبينهم يعبون نظام معقد وطويل
وبالتالي يضطرون لأنهم يتحدثون إلى أحد
يساعدهم ويستغل لهم هذا الشخص ويأخذ مباراة
إضافية لإستكمال هذه العمليات
أكيد في حل أفضل من ما يحدث
اليوم سنأخذ رحلة المستفيد كيف يستطيع
أن يسجل في الضمان الاجتماعي هل المنفذ
الوحيد هي المنصة؟ الجواب ليس هو المنفذ
الوحيد تستطيع تسجل من خلال المراكز الاتصال
وفي الحالات كبار السن وحالات الإعاقة
مراكز الاتصال أتكلم الكل
يعبي لك البيانات بشكل كامل
أيضًا كبار السن والإعاقة
بالإمكان أن الزملاء في الفروع ومكاتب
الضمان الاجتماعي يقدمون المساعدة بتسجيل
المستفيد عبر الضمان الاجتماعي
ليش نحرص اليوم على تقديم كل البيانات
وتدخيلها في المنصة؟ لأننا نسعى
اليوم إلى توفير منف للأسرة
يحدد كل الاحتياجات الموجودة عند الأسرة.
فاليوم قد تكون مستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي
ولكن عندك احتياجات أخرى أنت لست تعرف عنها.
احنا اليوم سهلنا الوصول لها.
فاحنا قاعدين نستهدف من خلال منصة الدعم والحماية
الاجتماعية نحاول أن نعرف من خلال الملف
الموحد اللي أنت تعبيه فيه كافة البيانات
بيانات الدخل، بيانات الاجتماعية، بيانات
السكن وغيرها من البيانات كيف أقدر أن أصل
لكل الاحتياجات اللي تحتاجها والمنصة تغطي
لك كل الدعوم المفترض أن تُقدم للأسرة فهي
نقطة ستساعد الأسر على المدى الطويل
وفي أن كل البرامج اللي المفترض أن
يستفيد منها أن تكون موفرة لهذا المستقبل
مادام في اتصال وزيارة الفرع فهذه خيارات متنوعة
ويظل تسهيل التجربة الرقمية هذا أكيد أنه
عمل مستمر وما ينتهي
في أسئلة كثيرة من الأيتام
وحالاتهم هنا سؤال مرّة غريب، يقول عندي يتيم أنا
الولي عليه قبل كان لحاله وينزل في حسابه
مبلغ الضمان الشهري بعد الضمان المطور
أجبروني أضيفه لأسرتي
والآن راتبي تجاوز الحد الأعلى قالوا خلاص ما نعطيه
رغم أنه يتيم ومستحق لمبلغ لأن فلوس
الضمان زكاة وهو من مستحقيها، فأيش تعليقك؟
إذا تتذكر لما تكلمنا عن الضمان اليوم فكرته
أصبحت تنظر إلى الأسرة بصورتها الكاملة
اليوم اليتيم، فيه برامج خاصة بالأيتام وفيه
دعم للأسرة الحاضنة يقدم
لأي أسرة تحتضن يتيم
وهذه دعوم مستقلة عن الضمان الاجتماعي
الضمان الاجتماعي اليوم لما يكون عندنا
فرد في هذه الأسرة هذا الفرد يعني حالته
على أي حيثية من الحيثيات اليتيم أو العاقة
أو غيرها فإنه في احتياجاته الأساسية هو
مشترك مع الأسرة في باقية الاحتياجات لذلك
احنا اليوم نقول ما هي احتياجات الأسرة
بصورتها الكاملة حتى نقدم لها الضمان
الاجتماعي، وفي نفس الوقت هذا اليتيم يقدم
للدعم الخاص بالأيتام وكذلك الدعوم الخاصة
بالأسرة الحاضنة تحتضن اليتيم
وعلى غرار ما ذكرناه في الدعم الخاص
بالإعاقة من خلال برامج التأهيل وغيرها
في سؤال كنت بتجاوزه، ولكن صاحبته كاتبة
دعاء طويل ما أقدر أني أتجاوز هذا السؤال
هي  تتكلم على شرحناها وغطيناها بس أبغى أن
أسألك على جزئية مختلفة في السؤال تقول
ليش الأرملة إذا توظفت ينحرمون أطفالها من
الضمان الاجتماعي، وينحرمون من مصاريف
المدارس، ورسوم قياس وحرمتونا من مكرمة الملك اللي كانت تجينا
في رمضان، وكنا نفرح فيها إذا الأم عندها
خمسة إيتام، وراتبها قليل كيف راح تغطي المصاريف؟
فذكرت مجموعة من حالات
الضرر اللي تصفها نتيجة أنها توظفت
و هي لو نظرت لدخل الوظيفة
لربما كان أوسع أفقًا من مبلغ الضمان لكن
ينظر لمبلغ الضمان بأنه حق ثابت فوق البيعة
ما نبغى يروح توظفت فهذا أبغاه ضمان دخل إضافي لي
أيش دوركم في توعية هؤلاء الأشخاص
للنظر إلى سعة الوظيفة ودخلها
مقابل محدودية الضمان
اللي ينتهي بحصولك على وظيفة بدخل عالي
الحالة يبدو لأنها توظفت فتوقف الضمان
عنها ومزايا الضمان عن أبنائها
التمكين ذكرنا فيه جزئية مهمة، وهي أنه يأخذ
الأشخاص من أشخاص متلقي للدعم
إلى أشخاص مكتفين عن الدعم
من خلال رفع المستوى المعيشي.
متى ما كان الدخل الوارد من الوظيفة
أقل من الحد المانع فإن الأسرة
ستستمر مستحقة للضمان الاجتماعي.
إذا كان الدخل الوارد من الوظائف أو الأعمال
أو غيرها يتجاوز بالأسرة لحد الأدنى احتساب
المعاش للضمان الاجتماعي تصبح الأسرة غير
مستحقة للضمان الاجتماعي في الحالة هذه مهم
أن نشير إلى جزئية مهمة لو نظرنا إلى
البرامج اللي أشارت لها، كل هذه البرامج
تُقدم للمستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي.
اليوم عندنا عفاء من رسوم القياس،
عندنا خدمات الوصول إلى المدارس، عندنا
خدمات الحقيبة والزي المدرسي، وغيرها
من الخدمات اللي تُقدم للمستفيدين.
للمستفيدين غير القادرين على تلبية هذه
الاحتياجات لأن هذه احتياجات احنا نعتبرها
احتياجات أساسية الحاجة للتعليم حاجة أساسية
ومهمة لكافة الأبناء إلّا متى ما كانت الأسرة
قادرة على توفير هذه الاحتياجات
فأصبحت الأسرة غير مستحقة لضمان اجتماعي لو
نظرت السائلة إلى حجم الدخل الحالي اليوم
لأصبحت أكثر معرفة وتصور إلى أن الدخل الجديد اللي
هو الدخل الناتج عن الوظيفة أصبح يغطي لي
احتياجاتي الموجودة اللي كان قبل يغطي جزء
منها الضمان الاجتماعي، أصبح الدخل الوارد من
الوظيفة دخل أعلى من الضمان الاجتماعي لو
قارنت بين هذين الرقمين لكتشفت قوة نوعية
هذا أنا أفهمها أبو إبراهيم
بس أنه يتجاوز 50%
أيش جهدكم في إيصالها لهم ورفع وعيهم
ولفت نظرهم لهذا الأفق الأوسع، في مرحلة أبو إبراهيم
و حتى بعض الناس كانوا يسألون عنها
أنه أول ما يحصل فيه تحديث
أو اشتراط جديد على الطول يوقف الدعم
و أبدأ نروح لاحق عشان أحدث معلوماتي عشان
يرجع الدعم أو الاستحقاق
أول ما أتوظف فورا يوقف في مرحلة في النص قد
تحتاج إلى إرشاد نفسي إرشاد معنوي إرشاد
في عدة جوانب لمساعدة هذا الشخص على تجاوز مرحلة
الاعتماد المطلق على موضوع الضمان، بمعنى أنه
هل تسوون جلسات أو إرشاد معين للشخص اللي يتوظف
راح ينقطع الضمان قبلما
تجيه اللحظة المزعجة هذه، يكون في اتصال
مباشر لا أظن أن تغريدة
يقرأها أو إعلاني يشاهدها في الشارع هي اللي
تفرق معها قد يكون الحوار المباشر مع شخص
مختص يشرح له سعة الأفق في هذا الجوانب و
الفرص الأكبر في الانطلاق لهذا العالم
الأرحب كل هذا لن تأتي بتغريدة
أو بوستر ستأتي بحوار مباشر يشارك فيه هذا
الضماني مخافة قلقة توجسة
و يستجيب الطرف الآخر ويناقشه ومن زاوية
نفسية يساعد على تقبلها
هل في شيء من هذا النوع؟
اليوم قبل أن تبدأ مرحلة التمكين
يجب أن يكون في تعاون ما بين المستفيد
وكذلك موظف الوزارة وهو موظف نسميه إدارة
الحالة الذي أشرت له قبل قليل من
الدور الذي يقوم به موظف إدارة الحالة لحالة
المستفيد هي توعية ما هي الإجراءات اللي
ستكون مستقبلية ومساعدته بحيث أن يكون متهيئ
بصورة كاملة للوصول إلى الإجراء اللي راح
يتبع كل خطوة من الخطوات الـ*
هذه تصير مع كل حالة؟
هذه تكون مع جميع الحالات اللي
يستهدف العمل معها التمكين المستفيدين
احنا عندنا إدارة الحالة المفترض أن يجلس
الموظف إدارة الحالة مع المستفيد
ويحاول أن يشرح له ويوصل له
ما هي الخطوات اللي تتم، ويساعده في اختيار
حتى النشاط المفترض أن يكون فيه، يعني هل المفترض
أن يكون عنده نشاط مثلًا اقتصادي أو هل مفترض
أن يكون لا مشاريع أو التدريب والدورات
والتأهيل اللي راح يوصله في النهاية إلى وظيفة
احنا في الوزارة أنشأنا عيادات خاصة، سميناها عيادات التمكين
ودور العيادات هي تقديم المعرفة هذه
للمستفيدين، نستقبل المستفيد فيها ونحاول
نعرف وين نقاط الخلل الموجودة عند المستفيد
كيف نستطيع نأخذ بيده لتجاوز أي تحدي
تحدي طبي أو تحدي اجتماعي
أيش الحاجز اللي يعيق المستفيد عن الوصول إلى التمكين
المفترض منه، أيضًا في إعادات التمكين نشرح
للمستفيد بصورة كاملة عن ما هي الخطوات
المستقبلية أنت اليوم راح تُقدم على خطوة
التمكين أيش الإجراءات الصحية؟ أنت راح تروح
بالجانب الاقتصادي أيش الفكرة اللي عندك؟ وش
تحتاجها؟ كيف أقدر أساعدك في دراسة الجدوى؟
من وين راح يكون في التمويل المالي؟ من هم
الشركاء الممكن يأخذون بيدك ويساعدونك
في تحقيق المستهدف اللي تطمح الوصول إليه
إعادات التمكين حققت العديد من الإنجازات
زارها كثير من المستفيدين الموجودين عندنا
في الضمان الاجتماعي وحقيقة سوّت نقلة كثيرة
للموجودين اليوم من خلال إعادات التمكين
كان يزورنا عدد من المستفيدين السابقين
فكان يجي يقول أنا فقط بس حاب أقول لكم ترى
أنا اللي كنت عندكم قبل فترة واليوم أنا
وصلت للمكان الفلاني وهذه حقيقة كانت رسائل
تعطي الفريق بصورة كاملة يعني دعم كبير أنه
بالفعل حالة بدأنا فيها قبل فترة واليوم هي
أصبحت في وضع
أكثر تميز وأكثر جودة احنا مثلما ذكرنا عندنا
مبادرة اللي هي مبادرة إطلاق العديد من
الحملات الإعلامية والتعاوير الشهدية
للمستفيدين الوزارة أطلقت عشرات الحملات
اللي سبقت إطلاق الضمان الاجتماعي وبعد
إطلاق الضمان الاجتماعي أصبح هناك عدد كبير
جدًّا من الحملات الإعلامية، ولعله أحد المنابر
الإعلامية اليوم لقائنا هذا أنه يعرف
المستفيدين بضمان الاجتماعي وما هي
الأشياء اللي يفترض أنه توفر لهذا المستفيد
وما هي الجهود والإجراءات الواجب على
المستفيد بدلها والمساعدة أنه تأخذ الوزارة
بيده للوصول إلى رفع المستوى المعيشي اليوم
الفكرة الأساسية هي تحويل المستفيد إلى
مستفيد مكتفي عن الدعم هذه نقطة أساسية
واحنا بالنسبة لنا في الوزارة وضعناها
الجزئية رقم واحد من الاهتمامات الخاصة بالمستفيدين
الضمانيين من المهم جدًّا الإشارة إلى أنه
عدد من اللقاءات الكثيرة اللي أشارت الوزارة
للمستفيدين من خلالها
عدد من المنابر اللي تحدثت من خلالها اليوم
عندنا حساباتنا على منصة إكس وكذلك عدد من
الظهور الإعلامي لظهرت الوزارة
موضوع مكافأة الجامعة أول ما تحسبوها الحين تحسبوها؟
المكافأة الجامعية لا تحسب من ضمن
الدخل اللي يحسب اليوم للضمانيين
هذه مؤكدة؟
ليش بعض الناس يقولون أنها تُحسب
ضمن دخل الأسرة
اليوم المستفيد لما يدخل البيانات أحيانًا
يدخل البيانات بصورة غير صحيحة فبدال ما يكتب
مكافأة يكتب راتب جامعي فلما تكتب راتب
تحول إلى عمل، بينما هي مكافأة وليست راتب
ممتاز هذا التوضيح
سؤال قبل الأخير
ليش تُحسب الحوالات الشخصية كدخل
وعلى أساسه استبعد من الضمان الاجتماعي
أنا أحيانًا أخذ قرض أصلح سيارة أو أرمم بيت
وأنوي أني أسددها من مبلغ الضمان
ولكن اول ما تشوفون حوالة تفكون عني الضمان
تحدث الحالات هذه؟
احنا عندنا ربط مع البنك المركزي
ومتى ما توفر في حساب المستفيد خلال فترة
ممتدة إلى ستة أشهر وجود مبالغ مرتفعة جدًّا
احنا نعتبر هذا الشخص لديه ما يوفر احتياجاته الأساسية
فلما خلنا أخذك في حالة، ونحاول نفهم أيش المقصود
بهذا الإجراء، لو افترضنا أن احنا عندنا أسرة
لديها حساب بنكي فيه مبلغ يتجاوز مثلًا يعني
خلينا نعطيك رقم 500 ألف أو 600 ألف في
الحساب وجالس هذا المبلغ من فترة طويلة
هذا المبلغ يستطيع تلبية الاختياجات الأساسية
فهل من الصحيح أنا راح أدفع معاش ضمان الاجتماعي
مثل ما ذكرنا أنه أحد مصادره الزكاة إلى أسرة
لديها في حسابها البنكي مبلغ عالي جدًّا
وهذه حالات محدودة اللي يستبين أنه
ما أظن أنه يقصد 500 ألف وأكيد أنه مبلغه أقل من كذا
تصليح سيارة بيكون عشرة ألاف أو إثنا عشر ألف
هذا القرض هل هذا مبالغ بالنسبة لكم؟
وش المعيار في أني أفهم أنه هذا قرض الرجال متسلف
عشان ما نحثهم على أنهم يروحون برّة النظام المالي
وهذه مخاطرها أكثر أنه
أنه يصير يعتمد على الكاش
والبنك المركزي ما راح يكون مبسوط في الحالة هذه
اليوم الضمان الاجتماهي ما ينظر إلى
المبالغ البسيطة عشر ألاف أو عشرين ألف أو ثلاثين ألف
اربعين ألف أو خمسين ألف ما ينظر إلى هذه المبالغ
أنها قد تكون مؤثرة في الحساب الضماني، ولكن
الإشكال لما يكون عندنا مبالغ
كبيرة وفي فترات طويلة موجودة في الحسابات
أحنا ما ندخل في تفاصيل هذه المبالغ أحنا
فقط نسأل هل المستفيد مستحق للضمان
الاجتماعي أو غير مستحق للضمان الاجتماعي؟
من خلال الربط الإلكتروني فإن هذا المستفيد
يكون غير مستحق للضمان الاجتماعي
أنا بختم أبو إبراهيم بسؤال يلخص كل هذه القصة
أنت الآن سنتين ونص في هذا البرنامج
أيش أكثر شيء تفتخر فيه؟
اليوم الضمان الإجتماعي حقيقة سوّا نقلة كبيرة
عندك عدد من التمكين اللي حصل للمستفيدين
عندك تغير في وصول المعاش إلى مستحقيه
لو نظرنا إلى المستفيد الحالي
نجد أن هذا الشخص لا يستطيع تلبية
احتجاته الأساسية وهذا الشخص الذي بالفعل
تنطبق عليه المعايير لإيصال مبلغ الزكاة أو
مبلغ معاش الضمان الاجتماعي لهذا المستفيد
في اليوم عندما أرى أن الضمان الاجتماعي
أصبح يصل إلى مستحقيه بالفعل وأصبحنا اليوم
نأخذ بيد هؤلاء المستفيدين للوصول إلى حالة
أعلى وحالة أوسع من مصدر الدخل وتحويل هؤلاء
الأشخاص من أشخاص متلقين للدعم فقط إلى
أشخاص أصبحوا منتجين اليوم لما نشوف حالات
في ملتقى التمكين مثلًا في المنطقة الشرقية
زارتنا أحد السيدات الكريمات
و ذكرت أنه أنا أحد الأسر اللي كنت أتلقى
الضمان الاجتماعي
و اليوم من خلال برامج التمكين الاجتماعي
أصبح لدي موظفين أنا أقدم لهم رواتر فلما
تشوف هذه الحالات هذه حقيقة تدعوك إلى الفخر
اليوم لما يشيد في جهودك البنك الدولي و
الدور اللي أنت تقوم فيه هذا حقيقة يدعوك
للفخر لما تشوف التنافس الكبير احنا عندنا
اليوم 430 ألف أسرة سعت للوصول إلى التمكين
هذا يدعوك للفخر عندما أرى أن لدي 200 ألف
أسرة استغنت بصورة كاملة عن الضمان
الاجتماعي هذا أمانةً يدعوني للفخر عندما أرى
التحول في الضمان الاجتماعي
اليوم الضمان الجديد في قرائة السعودية 2030
وضع أن تحديد الحد الأدنى لمعاش الضمان
الاجتماعي في المادة خمسة عشر بقرار
من مجلس الوزراء، فأصبح اليوم تدرس وزارة
المالية، ووزارة الاقتصاد، ووزارة الموارد
البشرية، الرقم الصحيح المفترض أنه يكون
مناسب ليكون الحد الأدنى تبع الاحتياجات الأساسية
فيصبح عندنا في سنة واحدة تغييرين
احنا انتقلنا من ألف ريال للعائل و280 إلى 1100
للتابع 550، بعد كذا نقلة أخرى خلال السنة 1320 للعائل
و 660 للتابع، أنت تتكلم حقيقة عن شيء بالفعل
يدعوك إلى الفخر اليوم من أعلى الهرم
الموجود عندنا في السعودية إلى جميع الفريق
الموجود في الوزارة
قاعد يسعى، ويتحرك بصورة حقيقية لتقديم الدعم
المباشر للمستفيدين
رؤية السعودية اليوم أمانةً كانت
تحول كبير، ونقطة انطلاق
واسع جدًّا للمستفيدين
حولت كثير من الأشخاص في فترات طويلة كان
متلقي للدعم كان شخص عنده كثير من التحديات
اليوم أصبح ينظر إلى
الحياة بنظرة طموحة ينظر بنظرة متفائلة أصبح
شخص مكتفي بنفسه معدوب بحاجة إلى دعم اجتماعي
هذه كلها حقيقة من صور الفخر اليوم لما
نشوف الجهود الكبيرة اللي تبذل
سمو ولي العهد
الفريق بالكامل نشوف فيه جهود وتعاون عالي
جدًّا مع هذه الفئة، وحرص أكيد
يخليني أمانةً بالفعل أشعر بالفخر بشكل كامل
ويجعل علي الحقيقة حمل كبير أن أحاول بالفعل
أظهر الصورة كما هي موجودة اليوم
الدعم العالي الدعم الكبير للأسرة تحولت من
واحد وثلاثين ألف كما ذكرنا في بداية اللقاء إلى ستين ألف
الأسرة بدعم كامل أنت تتكلم عن أرقام
كبيرة كافية إلى أن تساعد هذه الأسرة بالفعل
الانطلاق إلى الحياة بنظرة مختلفة
الكثير من البرامج المساندة دعم كهرباء، دعم
غذاء تتكلم عن تسهيل الوصول إلى المدارس
عندك الإعفاء من رسوم قياس
تتكلم عن دعم خاص بالحقيبة، والزي المدرسي
تتكلم عن دعوم كثيرة جدًّا قاعدة تُقدم
للمستفيد بصورة مباشرة في تعاون كبير من
الجهات عندنا تعاون مع الوزارات
بصورة عامة لما تشوف الحقيقة فيه إشادة
بالأعمال اللي قاعدة تقوم فيها هذا يدعوك
للفخر اليوم الوزارة حصلت على جائزة الملك
عبدالعزيز للجودة والتمييز المؤسسي
هذا بحد ذاته يعني يجعل الفريق بالكامل
يتقدم إلى الامام وهو سعيد لما أشوف أنه
احنا حصلنا على المركز الأول
في جائزة التواصل
مع فرق التطوع، وحصلنا عليها في إكسبو في
الشارقة في فترة ماضية، هذا يخلينا أمانةً أن
نكون بالفعل فخورين جدًّا، لما نحصل
في المرة التالية يعني مرتين على التوالي
نحصل على جائزة
في الجهود المبذولة في التحول الرقمي هذه
كلها تخليني أمانةً سعيد، لما أتواصل مع أسرة
ونحاول نُساعدها للحصول على الضمان
الاجتماعي، وبعد فترة أشوف التغير قاعد يصير
مع هذه الأسرة
والتقدم إلى الأمام والدعم الكبير اللي قاعد يصير
هذه كلها أمانةً تدعوني للفخر والإعتزاز
بالجهود المبذولة، وتخلي علي أمانةً
على المستوى الشخصي، وكذلك الفريق بشكل كامل
مهمة كبيرة، وهي كيف نقدر نطور، كيف نقدر نطلع
للأمام، أيش الخطوة القادمة؟
أنت لابد أن يكون عندك مواكبة للجهود
المبذولة بشكل كامل
وتعاون مع كافة الجهات بحيث أنه دائمًا تستمر
في المقدمة، اليوم إحنا عندنا الرضا عالي
الإشادة من جهات كثيرة، وجهات داخلية، وجهات
لها اعتبارها في العالم بصورة كاملة
كيف أنا أستطيع أحافظ على هذا المركز
وكيف أستطيع أزيد من الإنجاز وأستمر في المقدمة
ونسأل الله جل وعلا، الإعانة أنه بالفعل نُقدِّم ما يرضي
ونحقق الطموح ونستمر في البذل وتقديم ما يكون بالفعل يحقق
الطموح وكذلك الأمال الموجودة في رؤية السعودية
وكذلك تحقيق الحاجة اللي تكون عند مستفيدينا
وتكون خدماتنا على أعلى مستوى هذا أمانةًً
الطموح بشكل كامل
ونظرتنا ما لها حدود
اليوم همتنا مثلما ذكر سمو سيدي ولي العهد كجبل طويق
احنا همتنا عالية، ونتمنى بالفعل أنه يكون عندنا تُقدم عالي
وهذا أمانةً ما نستهدفه
عندنا مشاريع كبيرة نستهدف الوصول لها
قاعدين نحاول أن نزيد من خدماتنا بشكل كبير
عندنا رضا عالي بالخدمات المقدمة
ولكن طموحنا الكبير يخلي المهمة بالنسبة لنا مهمة أساسية
وأكيدة وإصرارنا عالي، فإنه بالفعل
راح نحقق المستهدفات
وراح نتجاوز، ونرسم مستهدفات أبعد وراح يستمر
هذا الأمر، بإذن الله، مدام رؤية السعودية
الحقيق الطموحة بشكل عالي جدًّا
ومدام، الحمد لله، الدعم الكبير اللي قاعد يحصل عليها
الضمان الاجتماعي من قيادته الكريمة
فلابد أن احنا نبذل كل ما نستطيعه، بحيث نتوافق
ونتواكب مع هذا الدعم الكبير وللّا محدود
بإذن الله تعالى، عساكم عالقوة
وشكرًا يا أبو إبراهيم
الله يعطيك العافية
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لفهد القصيَر، في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة.
ياسر آل غان، في إدارة التصوير.
في الإضاءة: أسماعيل شوقي وسعيد عمر.
في تسجيل الصوت: عبدالعزيز المزي.
وفي التحرير: مرامض بيبان.
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن.
وفي إدارة الإنتاج: عبدالمجيد عمر.
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: غيداء التميمي.
هذا سقراط أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع